PERCENTAGE TRYING TO BOUNCE BACK
FROM A VERY DIFFICULT SEASON A
YEAR AGO.
HE GETS
VICTORY.
IT COST ALAIN VIGNEAULT HIS JOB.
IT SHOULDN'T MATTER FOR A YOUNG
GUY LIKE THIS, BEC
20, BECAME THE YOUNGEST
GOALTENDER EVER TO PLAY INPUCKS.
>> JOHN: HERE'S THE
GOAL POST INSIDE OF CAREER, AFT
APPEARING IN THE FIRST 403
GAMES.
>> Brian SIDE OF THE NET AND TH
TURNED INTO A GREAT OPPPP
FLETCHER SAID BOTH PROVOROV AND
NEUTRAL ZONE.
WATCH TROY TERRY JUST KEEP AN
EYE ON HIM, HE'S UP HIGH, GETS
THEE DEBUT KEEPS IT ON THE
INBOARDS AND BACK TO AWAY AS TH
FLYERS TO
THE LEAD IN HALF.
>> Brian: TAKES OVER IN
PHILADELPHIA.
VETERAN FIRES IT
THEER.
AND YOU SAW DRYSDALE DO A LITTLE
BIT OF A FLY AND KONECNY THE OT
WAY FOR THE FLYERS STICK OF JOS
MANSON AND RIGHT BACK TO KONECNY
AND WHAT A TO HAVE SEEN NUMBER .
THAT SHIP HAS HAS
TO MOVE BECAUSE OF THE QUICKNESS
OF van RIEMSDYK, AND, BOY, TO B
AGAINST CARTER HART.
HART OUT
HIGH JOINED BY MILANO
AL-KILLING UNIT IS THAT
SOMETIMES THE FORWARDS RIGHT SI
THE PUCK ALL THE TIME?
ARE THEY, YOU KNOW,
TO TAG UP THAT BUYS TIME FOR
FOWLER, HIS PASS UP THE   THE F
HIS SKATS GASSED RIGHT NOW.
>> John: S S CHANGEUP
SHOT, GIBSON ABLE TO KEEP IT OU.
LINDBLOM COMES UP WITH IT
THTH THE GAME WINNER.
AND 20 ON THE THE
MIDDLE, DOWN LOW PASS
AND GOES RIGHT BACK OUT THE
OTHER SIDE.
BOY, WHAT
SHATTENKIRK MOVING IT AROUND THE
PERIMETER, COMTOIS TO ACROSS, UO
PLAY IN THE A NIGHT, HIS
FIRST CAREER HAT TRICK AT THE
NATIONAL HOCKEY LEAGUE LEVEL.L.